alors que la fréquentation nationale des
salles obscures est irrégulière ces
derniers mois duboc ans espère tirer son
épingle du jeu
un mois après la réouverture du ciné 7 à
elancourt
le bilan est positif au mois d'avril
2010 qui est notre dernière période de
référence puisqu'on a été fermée après
là on est sensiblement dans les mêmes
chiffres dont plus de 6000 entrées donc
on est plutôt très content on a des
petits soucis des petits calage
évidemment qu'ils sont liés à l'essuyage
de plâtre on peut appeler ça comme ça il
faut qu'on organise mieux on le sait on
s'en excuse à l'euro près des gens par
rapport aux files d'attentes parce qu'on
a eu pas mal de critiques à dessus et
c'est normal parce que il faut trouver
le bon le bon mode de fonctionnement
je crois qu'on est en train de le
trouver quelques ajustements en terme
d'organisation sont encore nécessaires
pour parfaire l'accueil du public un
public composé de curieuses et deux
fidèles
on retrouve nos habitués des gens qu'on
connaît bien qui fréquentent le cinéma
depuis des années et on a aussi des gens
qu'on n'a jamais vus je pense certains
qui viennent du multiplexe qui ont
l'habitude d'aller au multiplexe parce
que je pense c'est l'histoire de
lunettes 3d en disant ça qui arrive avec
les lunettes 3d qu'ils ont acheté
multiplexe et comme ce n'est pas le même
système qu'ici qu'on leur explique et
c'est donc à un énorme effet de
curiosité on l'a vu les premières
semaines ça se tasse un peu il y avait
des gens qui venaient simplement pour
visiter une nouveauté à laquelle le
public doit encore s'habituer au ciné
cette pour assister aux séances en 3d
les spectateurs devront s'équiper de
lunettes dynamique permettant la
restitution active de l'image ces
lunettes sont disponibles à la location
pour un coût de 2 euros par séance